The devil.
Alhamdulillah. for
[Silence]
my
Continuing where we left off
with regards to the story of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam's first
receiving revelation
first receiving
verses of the Quran from Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
These verses we mentioned that
revelation comes to the prophets and
messengers in different ways.
There are levels
and methods of revelation
that are mentioned throughout the Quran
mentioned in the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
One of these is in the form of
premonition during sleep.
Now this premonition during sleep where
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam would
see in a dream something that he would
see in a dream whether it be he or any
of the other prophets or messengers.
Is it
that any verses of the Quran were
revealed to the prophet Sam
in his sleep?
The answer is we do not have any
authentic narrations or evidence
indicating that the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam ever received any verses
of the Quran in his sleep.
Is it possible?
Is there anything particularly wrong
with that? No. It's just that there
aren't any authentic evidences
that indicate that he received any
verses of the Quran
in other than his state of wake.
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Another
question that comes up with regards to
receiving the verses of the Quran.
Has there ever been an a time where
other than
brought verses of the Quran to him?
There are no authentic narrations
which indicate that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
was ever brought verses of the Quran by
any other angel other than Gi
whether that be Mika or whether that be
any other angels. Other angels may have
brought certain knowledge about the
Quran about
the Quran.
there's an irration for instance in
which the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
was with Jirelam
and they heard a sound from above
and so he looked up and Jirelam
said to him that sound is the sound of a
door to the heavens which has never been
opened before.
And an angel descended
upon him and said to him,
[Silence]
He said to him,
, glad tidings, good news of,
, two lights that no prophet was ever
given before you,
the chapter of
and the closing two verses of Bakar.
So we see that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
sent these
this angel to inform him about verses of
the Quran
but never that he sent to him angels
other than Giblis
who brought to him verses of the Quran.
That was the
sole dominion of Jirelam.
And so what we know from the authentic
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam is that the Quran
was revealed to him in its entirety by
Giblam
only.
And the Quran was revealed to him in its
entirety while he was in awake of while
he was in a state of wakefulness.
I'm saying this because
a lot of times when people read
certain books or open certain articles
and especially now on the internet and
people can pretty much upload anything
that they want and they can you know
manipulate algorithms and search
engines to to prioritize what they
say. not necessarily based on merit or
credibility.
There are a lot of narrations floating
around that people read and they're
unable to discern. Is this authentic? Is
this inauthentic? Many narrations which
are not even from the books of Sunnah.
Many narrations which come from the
books of the or the Shia. Many
narrations that are fabricated and so
forth. And so it's important for us to
only read from the most authentic
sources.
And in general,
in general,
as a rule of thumb,
never read something
without knowing for a fact that it is
credible. Don't ever just read it and
think, "You know, if it's if it's not
credible, I can deal with it later." No,
you're essentially
polluting your heart and your mind
with things that you have to later try
to scrub out of your mind and out of
your heart. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam used to seek refuge in Allah
from knowledge which is unbeneficial,
let alone knowledge which is harmful.
And the scholars have agreed that it is
impermissible
to learn knowledge which is harmful.
And so
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
received these first verses the first
five verses of
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala began
speaking to him. He said to him
Now here we have a question and we've
heard most of us already know this even
if you didn't hear our previous
mention of this in Aisha's narration
and that is that Jirelam
didn't just relate these words to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
actually reached out and touched him he
grabbed him and he squeezed him and he
scared him really badly.
Why was that? Why did Jirelam
take him and squeeze him? So when Jirel
first came, he said
and the prophet's response
for.
[Silence]
So he mentions that began with the first
word. Now this he was repeating this
word over and over this opening word in
order to grab his attention in order to
cement in his mind the first and
opening words of these verses. But why
did Jirel take him and squeeze him? The
prophet sallall.aii Wasam said he
squeezed me until I was breathless and
then he let me go and he said to me
again repeating
and I said I I'm not able to read and so
he took me a second time and he squeezed
me and a third time. Why did he squeeze
him? What was the point of this? There
is an issue that comes up that we have
to
examine the rest of what was revealed
to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam of
the Quran. Is there any verse in the
Quran
which categorically
tells us that the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam saw Allah.
The answer is no. There's no evidence in
the Quran
that the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
wasam saw Allah. As a matter of fact,
there's no evidence in the Sunnah that
he saw Allah. And this is a well-known
issue that some of the companions had
discussed and debated amongst one
another allegedly
that
to the point that she said
whoever tells you that Muhammad saw his
Lord then he has lied to you or he has
made a mistake. He is mistaken. Whoever
tells you that, right? She was so
certain that he had never seen Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala physically with his
eyes. Physically with his eyes
and others of the companions.
It's mentioned by Abbas that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam saw Allah with his
heart.
He saw him with his heart, meaning
whether it be in his time of sleep or a
kind of spiritual vision, but never with
his eyes.
our manba,
one of the great scholars of hadith, he
mentions that the companions all agree
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
did not physically see Allah. But here's
another point
and that is that the companions all
agree categorically
that the prophet sallall.aii was did see
Jirel and not only did he see him but he
saw him in his original form that he was
created in. The prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam said he had 600 wings
twice he saw him in his original form
and this is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
takes special care to mention this in
multiple places throughout the Quran in
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
says that Muhammad Sallallah.aii
wasallam saw Ji
saw him not only saw him in this form or
that but saw him even in his most
original form that he was created in.
Why is that important information for us
to know? Why is it important for us to
know that Jirelam
was seen by the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
and that it is of the most utmost of
importance that we know this?
Why did Jirel
take
time and take care to reach out on the
first meeting with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and squeeze
him not touch him not a little bit
squeeze him until he was breathless
saiam
why did this happen why is it so
important for us to know this
mentions in his books,
he mentions
that
it is more necessary
for us to know
that Muhammad Sam
than it is for us to know if Muhammad
saw Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. It
doesn't mean that seeing Allah is not as
profound. Obviously seeing Allah would
be far more profound than seeing Gi.
But for the purposes of revelation
and the implications of that, it is more
important that Muhammad Sam
see Jirel
and that he has interacted with him
physically.
Jirelam reached out and pulled him and
squeezed him until the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam had a physiological
response. Why? In order to distinguish
between
a hallucination, a trick of the mind.
I saw something but I'm not sure what I
saw. No, this is unmistakable. It was a
physical thing. It has a physical effect
on his body and not I think I felt
something more along the lines of I
almost lost consciousness. It was so
vivid and so intense.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
had commanded
that when he left that cave when he left
the cave of on that night that he leave
not even a shred of doubt in the
prophet's mind sallallam
with regards to who he was speaking to.
It could not be something that was I
think I heard something, I felt
something. It was paramount that he know
that this was an angel from Allah that
was not something a figment of my
imagination.
Rather, this was a physical being
outside of myself who reached out and
touched my body, not just my mind or my
heart.
Because the claim that the antagonists
of the prophets and the messengers have
throughout time is that they
claim or accuse their prophets of
being of aljun
al jun they they accuse their prophets
of insanity. And this word alun
comes originally from jin meaning that a
person is possessed that a person is
possessed by a demon or a person is
being plagued by a demon that has caused
him to lose his mind. These are not
things that the prophets actually see or
interact with. rather these are just
impulses or their subconscious
leaping forward and making them think
that they saw etc etc and so in order to
remove all doubt of that Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
made it that the prophet Sam
saw
he saw him on each time that the Quran
was brought to him he physically ally
interacted with him. And not only that,
but he saw him in his original form that
the earth in all of its size could not
accommodate.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said,
"But
I saw Jirel in his original form which
Allah created him in. He had 600 wings
and he had completely sealed off the
entire visible horizon."
And for this reason Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala outlines for us
in
that the prophet Muhammad saw.
And it is so necessary and important
that a person cannot be Muslim if they
do not believe
that Muhammad saw
And so starting on Sunday inshallah
we will relate the remaining portion of
the narration and go into the
explanation of surah
and we will go through the entire surah.
These five verses are the first verses.
after these five verses
to that verse then Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala sent down
and then
and the remaining portion of
was later revealed after
as a matter of fact apparently years
after
this first portion of the chapter was
revealed but we will go through the
entire surah together just so that we
will have a a complete picture. It will
starkly contrast when he f the
comparison between when he first
received revelation and later on when
his revelation became public and how his
people and his family responded to this
revelation. We ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
that he subhanahu wa ta'ala teach us
that which will benefit us and that he
benefit us from that which he teaches us
that he only teach us the most important
and critical for our lives and for our
deaths and that he subhanahu wa'ta'ala
clear our minds and our hearts of any
corruption or misunderstanding or
misguidance
Just a reminder, tomorrow night,
inshallah, we'll have our questions and
answers, our weekly questions and
answers. Inshallah, if you want to
prepare your questions, if you have
any written down or anything that,
we'll be taking them tomorrow after